arme nucléaire défensive et offensive au
sol en mer et dans les airs avec les
Américains les Russes sont les seuls à
disposer de tout l'arsenal stratégique
Moscou compte même le plus grand stock
d'armes nucléaires au monde selon
l'Observatoire cyprique il se composait
l'année dernière de 6255
ogives un peu plus que son rival
américain les deux pays disposent à eux
deux de 90% du stock mondial plus de
1600 missiles russes seraient
actuellement déployés cela signifie
qu'ils sont prêts à être tirés
rapidement par l'armée russe
parmi ces Arsenal il y a l'effrayant
rs28 sarmat surnommée Satan II par
l'OTAN la plus grosse arme
intercontinentale jamais conçue selon
les autorités russes sont rayon d'action
dépasse les 10 000 km il pourrait
détruire un territoire d'une taille
égale à la France mais comme les pays
disposant de la puissance nucléaire
Moscou s'en sert avant tout comme une
force de dissuasion
ces armes dévastatrices risquent
désormais d'être déployés en dehors de
la Russie l'Allier biélorus vient de
réformer sa constitution en autorisant
la présence de missiles nucléaire sur
son sol
nous savons ce que cela signifie pour la
Biélorussie d'être nucléaire cela
signifie que la Russie mettra des armes
nucléaires en Biélorussie et c'est une
voie très dangereuse
les récentes déclarations de Vladimir
Poutine sous-entendant une possible
utilisation de l'arme nucléaire on fait
monter d'un cran les tensions en 2014
déjà lors de l'annexion de la Crimée le
président russe avait fait référence à
son statut depuis son snucléaire pour
décourager toute riposte